this course presents a range of  perspectives about the future of crypto  there's no wild-eyed optimism and  there's no gloomy pessimism there is  instead an opportunity to grapple with  the very real challenges that crypto's  going to present  these challenges are going to be  technological  they're going to be economic  they're going to be related to  governance mechanisms they're going to  be legal  the best way to understand the future of  crypto is to look at it  realistically not to take an overly  optimistic view not to take an overly  pessimistic view but to grapple with the  real world challenges that confront us  all